chaque enfant a une fée née
juste pour eux clochette est née pour
toi
c'est juste
qu'elle est pressée de grandir
il rêve d'explorer de nouvelles terres qui sont
ces sales vagabonds
et qu'ont ils fait de mes
enfants c'est l'histoire inédite
de  un frère et une soeur deux
aventuriers de la même famille
notre alice et
comment est-il il est toujours le patron
le garçon perdu est à votre service
dette
j'ai besoin de plus de temps éloigne moi d'elle
peter ne laisse pas la vie t'abattre tu
continue juste à flotter au dessus
[Applaudissements]
et quels sont vos noms
nous pouvons tous utiliser un peu plus de courage
maintenant
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le moment de grandir  notre palais
jamais peter
tu te verras